aquí tenemos una serie infinita la suma
desde n igual a cero hasta infinito de
menos 1 elevado a la n que multiplica a
x elevado a la 6 n sobre 2 n factorial y
mi objetivo en este vídeo es evaluar
esta serie de potencias cuando x es
igual a la raíz cúbica de pi sobre 2 te
invito a que le pongas pausa el vídeo y
lo intentes por tu cuenta te voy a dar
una pista determina a qué función se
refiere esta serie de potencias y
entonces evalúa la cuando x tiene este
valor y aquí te doy otra pista observa
que este es un número extraño un número
misterioso y sobre dos que este tipo de
números que utilizamos cuando evaluamos
funciones trigonométricas y ahora te
dejo que lo intentes por tu cuenta
supongo que ya lo intentaste ahora
hagámoslo juntos en este tipo de
problemas
me gusta darme cuenta de que se trata
expandiendo los primeros términos de la
serie de potencias así es que al
expandir esta serie el primer término
cuando en es igual a cero
- 10 es uno de hecho todo el primer
término es uno cuando en es igual a 1
esto es menos 1 a la 1 - 1 x a la sexta
sobre 2 factorial luego más menos 1 al
cuadrado es más 1 x a la 12 x elevado a
la 12 sobre 4 factorial vamos a hacer un
último término menos equis elevado a la
18 sobre 6 factorial y así continúan los
infinitos términos de esta serie ahora a
simple vista no se me ocurre una función
trigonométricas que esté representada
por esta serie y estoy pensando en
función trigonométricas debido a este
número que tenemos aquí en términos de
pi sobre 2 no se me ocurre a simple
vista pero si se ve sospechosamente
familiar viéndolo bien esto se parece
mucho a la serie maclaurin para coseno
de x la cual ya hemos visto varias veces
recordemos como es el vídeo previo que
hemos hecho
mack loring para coseno de x establece
claramente cómo llegamos a esto la serie
de mac loring para coseno de x es igual
a o aproximadamente igual solo voy a
hacer algunos términos es
aproximadamente igual a 1 - x cuadrada
sobre 2 factorial más x a la cuarta
sobre 4 factorial menos x a la sexta
sobre 6 factorial y así sucesivamente y
aquí ya vemos la similitud el primer
término es igual aquí tenemos menos más
menos aquí también tenemos menos más
menos aquí tenemos entre 2 factorial 4
factorial 6 factorial la única
diferencia son las potencias de x aquí
tenemos x a la sexta aquí quizá al
cuadrado
aquí tenemos x a la cuarta aquí x a la
doceava aquí quizá la sexta aquí x a la
ahora tenemos que pensar de qué manera
podemos reemplazar x aquí porque qué
sucede por ejemplo cuando expandimos la
serie para coseno de a más b en ese caso
cuando desarrollamos la serie en lugar
de x vamos a tener a + b la pregunta es
podemos encontrar alguna potencia de x
de tal manera que esto de aquí se hace
igual a esto de acá bien esto de aquí x
a lasexta esto de aquí es lo mismo que x
al cubo elevado al cuadrado
aquí tenemos x a la doceava que es lo
mismo que quizá al cubo
elevado a la cuarta mientras que x
elevado a la 18
es lo mismo que quizá al cubo elevado a
la sexta así es que si reemplazamos cada
una de las equis que tenemos aquí por x
al cubo vamos a obtener esta serie que
tenemos acá es decir estamos obteniendo
la expansión en serie de potencias de
coseno de x cúbica déjame hacerlo con
otro color así que el co seno de ese no
es otro color
el coseno de x kubica
va a ser igual de nueva cuenta en lugar
de x voy a sustituir x cúbica 1 menos
buena el paréntesis elevado al cuadrado
sobre 2 factorial no de hecho deja de
escribir esto en el verde lo va a poner
en el verde original
así es que esto es igual a 1 menos
paréntesis elevado al cuadrado sobre 2
factorial más paréntesis elevado a la
cuarta sobre 4 factorial menos
paréntesis elevado a la sexta sobre 6
factorial y ahora sí vamos a poner en
color malva el argumento de coseno que
es x cúbica
aquí tenemos x cúbica elevado al
cuadrado aquí x cúbica elevado a la
cuarta y aquí x cúbica elevado a la
sexta lo cual vemos que es exactamente
lo que tenemos aquí así es que esta es
la serie de potencias para coseno de x
kubica así es que evaluar esto cuando x
es igual a la raíz cúbica de pi sobre 2
es lo mismo que evaluar esto cuando x es
igual a la raíz cúbica de pi sobre 2
vamos a escribir eso esto ya se puso
interesante así es que la suma desde n
igual a cero
hasta infinito de menos 1 elevado a la n
que multiplica a x elevado a la 6 n
sobre 12 n factorial esto es igual esto
es igual al coseno de x cúbica coseno de
x elevado al cubo
ahora cuando x es igual a la raíz cúbica
de pi sobre 2 sabemos la razón de este
misterioso número al elevar al cubo la
raíz cúbica ésta se va a eliminar de tal
manera que el coseno de la raíz cúbica
de y sobre 2
todo esto elevado al cubo es igual
simplemente al co seno de iu sobre 2 que
por supuesto es igual a 0 y así hemos
concluido